are we alone in the universe I've always
been persuaded by the pure statistical
argument that given the scale of it
there's bound to be and you mentioned
yourself you talked about there's loads
of planets and the Goldilocks on uh all
around the universe surely there's
intelligent life somewhere out there
right statistically speaking right so so
that I like to make the the following
analogy so I believe that there's no
intelligent life in the universe yeah
especially if I mean especially on this
planet yeah that's right this this
planet's uh the worst except for all the
others yeah
um so uh I believe that we become very
uh enamored of this notion again there
is some primordial Beauty to the notion
of escaping and thinking about things
that transcend our limitations of time
or space or existence and one of those
is the existence of other life forms
that may exist in in the universe first
of all we can say there's zero evidence
for such life forms even a slime mold on
Enceladus you know in our own solar
system there's no evidence for it and
that's important because uh there is a
concept purported by by the man who
coined the term Big Bang actually you
guys are the perfect people asses I've
never gotten a straight answer is Big
Bang a dirty word is it a dirty phrase
no no no because supposedly Hoyle Fred
Hoyle sir Fred Hoyle is one of the
greatest astronomers in history he
coined the term Big Bang as a pejorative
meaning orgasm ah so that's never said
in this country we had a better sex
lives but uh no I didn't know that no I
don't think nobody would do it so he was
he was a proponent of the steady state
model uh but but in any case he uh the
he also came up with the notion of
what's called panspermia can I say that
on the show yeah whatever you want it's
a free speech that's a free speech so
the notion of what's called panspermia
it means that uh that there will be
exchange of material between planets and
between other star systems in our galaxy
and that will potentially uh be a and
almost like a Noah's Ark for life to
transport it doesn't solve the origin of
Life problem but it could potentially
solve the abundance of Life problem in
our solar system or how how did it come
here he claimed could have come from
another another planet uh not too far
away by Cosmic standards so it gets here
now I actually have some of this and as
we said there's meteorites and so forth
they're found in Antarctica it's well
known phenomenon I actually have a tiny
piece of Mars it doesn't have any amino
acids or DNA or a little uh green men on
it but it comes comes from Mars and we
can prove it comes from Mars uh just
trust me we have it from many other
bodies in our solar system so why is
that important that means that things
can come here well guess what that means
that things can go from the earth out
there right so you have to answer the
question what is the probability and
what does it say about life in the
universe that we haven't found life say
on Mars now Mars a big place and yeah if
we went somewhere on Earth but almost
everywhere on Earth has life almost
everywhere even Antarctica where I've
been Antarctica is one-seventh of the
total number of continents on this
planet it's about the size of Australia
uh so it's pretty it's pretty big
there's almost no life there though
there's almost no there is life there's
microbial life there are these giant
birds called skuas uh that will like
take a toddler away if the toddlers were
allowed on the content notes or not
um and then there's sea lions a couple
Penguins on the coast that's about it
there's no polar bears or anything like
that
um and then there's humans so you're
talking about you know this vast
continent the size of Australia hundreds
of times you know tens of times bigger
than the UK
no life almost no life but if you make
the argument that life should be
abundant or based on statistical
probability as Fermi did Enrico Fermi
one of the greatest physicists he
created What's called the Fermi Paradox
there's so many planets there's so many
go they didn't know about the Goldilocks
zone back then but they said if uh if
the average lifetime of a technological
civilization is even a million years
then just in the age of our galaxy which
is which is maybe eight billion years or
more uh that means we should have been
visited by thousands and even going at a
slow chemical rocket speed so he asked
the famous question where are they so we
have to ask where are they and and come
up with solutions to that Fermi Paradox
and there are many purported solutions
but one of which is there are no aliens
right I mean the most simple thing based
on evidence is that there are no
certainly technological civilizations
that we're aware of there could be
beyond what we're uh where now the best
calculations do the following they don't
say and as I don't say I don't say
there's no life I say the probability is
very small uh and certainly even smaller
for technological life it has to be even
smaller right if there's a dolphin
swimming on a pool and Enceladus we're
never going to know about it because it
doesn't have an iPhone to let us know
that we live there unless we stumble
upon it right so it has to be
technological how do we get to that
technology comes back to what we said
before we start with primitive things
maybe our hydrocarbons necessary is
global warming a trademark a Hallmark of
civilization some say it is in other
words we should look not for uh
Transmissions of you know I Love Lucy
but we should look for global warming on
another planet so far we haven't seen it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist but that
would mean terraforming and modifying
the that particular client then did they
have a biosphere
did they have chlorophyll do they have a
great oxidation event did they have a
Jupiter that sucks up deadly asteroids
from impacting the the Earth or whatever
the analog Earth is in the Goldilocks
zone that's not in the Goldilocks zone
do they have a moon that's at the exact
right distance to create tides that can
cause chemical intubation almost between
uh life Land and Sea uh do they have
plate tectonics that we talked about are
those plate tectonics lubricated by
these microorganisms so there's many
different hurdles and the way I like to
say it is so you can phrase it like this
imagine that there were eight things
that had to happen for us to have this
conversation under these Lights and
Camera right they had to be a big bang
you know there had to be uh the
formation of matter from no matter so
people think that a matter is conserved
it's not energy is conserved but matters
now then there had to be primitive
elements that could support life then
life had to come about and be conscious
than that life that was conscious how to
create technology and so forth so you
just go through and you say it like this
and then there had to be things that
prevented it asteroids are going to be
dinosaurs that got that were there but
got killed off and fossils and so you
didn't say there's eight of them and
each one has a probability of one in a
thousand that's it just say one in a
thousand that there's a big bang
whatever that means one of the Thousand
that there's a Jupiter one thousand and
we know the probabilities are much much
much lower let's just say for the sake
of the argument one divided by a
thousand eight of those you take one
over a thousand you raise it to the
eighth power you get one in 10 to the
24th that same number is the inverse of
the number of planets we think there are
in the observable universe's history so
over 13.8 billion years we think there
have been 10 to the 24th which is a
trillion trillion planets that could be
life inhabiting but the probability I
just said is one in 10 to the 24th so
that so the problem comes about the
human mind is incapable of multiplying a
zero by an infinity and that's why the
statistical argument I think is a very
crude but often overestimate of the
probability of possibility of technology
so
the emergence of life on Earth is so
ridiculously unlikely that's right that
for that to be replicated anywhere in
the universe even with the number of
planets that exist is still
extraordinarily unlikely because it was
so unlikely that it was formed here yeah
and there's so many contingent things
that have to occur it's just the right
order